most of us call this our cookies own
international sweets are interesting
some of them are gooey and drippy and
flaky I happen to have a particular
fondness for marzipan I personally like
fruit so here we have a jeera biscuit
from India it looks almost like a
gingersnap tastes like there's beans in
it kind of remind you of those
shortbread cookies a little bit doesn't
have a whole lot of sugar which is good
tastes like cornmeal there might be a
little baking soda or something in there
it's Lakey if you like that crumbling
crumbs insane in your mouth I I guess
someone might like that looks like a
nice little maple leaf let's see what it
tastes like tastes like maple reminds me
of little animal crackers that you might
had when you and your kid got the
frosted ones just the plain brown ones
and she crumbly it has a dramatic graham
cracker aftertaste reminds me of when I
was a kid and my mom used to mix up
peanut butter and honey and put it on
bread for us we're gonna take just a
little bit of it off like this and we're
gonna place it on the tip of my tongue
almost a marzipan equality to it that's
a dandy the old Australian Tim Tim today
mate g'day mate listen Santa from Down
Under
chocolate it reminds me of making
chocolate cake with my grandmother nice
crunch the chocolate it doesn't just
jump out at you you lies there in the
mouth saying say to me no kind of
central superb aftertaste I have to go
to Australia again
a beetle has a density kind of feel of a
madona
as a lot more to than I was expecting
mm-hmm big overgrown Twinkie maybe two
Twinkies uncle it does have a real eggy
kind of a feel too and you know that
you're going to enjoy it down to the
last bite
well they were all delicious this Santa
says Bravo and a big two thumbs up
you've hit some unusual ones here today
that's the beauty of the world we all
have our different cultures and you know
have a different tastes but I love the
brand crapper outside San Jose and
graham crapper